the cards in my earth position pawn to
c4 has been played by the other goes e6
which
i guess is the most
common choice amongst top players these
days mount jarv has been a big gruntful
player for many years as well of course
here he goes for e6 and carlson sticks
to the catalan his new weapon of choice
it looks like yeah appears to just be
solidly his number one choice uh
he's been playing
a lot of that recently and i've always
liked it as an opening much more than
some of the other things you can do
again in the let's say d4 another six
slash d45 complex of of openings yeah
they look interesting
so castles castles and magnus plays e3
quite a quite a move trying to avoid
maybe some of these sharp lines you
mentioned earlier with queen c1 and
quincy two could still be unpleasant
well this is actually similar to what
they got right in this particular case
it doesn't necessarily work or we could
just take it and if cb before we take
the bishop and if
bishop takes we have knight fd2 and you
can't recover
yeah so maybe
yeah
exactly it will be very difficult to
justify developing your pieces in such a
manner if after that white just wins the
pawn back very comfortably
queen c2 plate pawn to b5 pawn to a4
the the magnus catalan is going to be
very very interesting uh i'm on the rf
chose daw3 you mentioned bishop c3 i
mentioned bishop b7 he went rook b6
saying i want to keep the pawn
yeah he he he found the move he liked
which protected the pawn on b5 i just i
really hated bishop d7
didn't even want to think about queen
queen the seven queen either queen b6
and that's why i took on c3 but aerobics
looks like a sensible other choice
not committing the bishop c3 yet and
defending the pawn
[Music]
first and foremost i think as most most
people who have ever had to address this
question
i'm in this debate and the move shock
made here i'm very invested in trying to
investigate
because i have a feeling i know why he
did this
and it's very very
daring and interesting to me
because like it looks like it loses by
force because of e5 and if the knight
has to go back i think you're just
completely lost on it like it feels to
me like it's unplayable if it goes back
yeah he clearly didn't like that
position we were discussing i think i
think it's very obvious that
so c was not
we could still get something yeah
there's also night before right but like
before might be a relevant conclusion
what could it be right i'm reading that
mama the era of blundered which always
to be taken with yeah
but apparently the computer doesn't like
what he did he did insist on this
exchange sacrifice
now knights of six this is the position
we looked at
doesn't look like a
no no definitely definitely not the
blunder but yeah maybe this is this
particular version of the
positional exchange sacrifices
that's what is saying well you have
played well i guess no blender yeah yet
certainly didn't look like but probably
the computer
feels this good for what yeah this was
not an oversight
little machine on site was very very
much in favor of the exchange sacrifice
which jan proposed
uh before we went off air for a bit
uh specifically rook c8 rook c8 between
queen five with the idea of
very importantly the knight on ic6 does
not really have any good squares to uh i
mean you can play knight a7 here which
does protect the rook on c8 and stop c5
v6 but knight a7 in itself is such an
ugly move to make that i don't think
it's
a very attractive option so what ends up
happening is black probably plays
something like rook of fate and white
goes e6
and uh
this looks very very dangerous for black
but apparently even the position they
have on the board right now is also
pretty good
even though those tactics are
no longer in play
pretty good at least on a previous move
and apparently now magnus we're being
told by computer experts is
maybe just winning even though
it still doesn't really look that way it
looks like he might he might be better
but it doesn't look like he's winning so
was rook cafe one bishop e6 played yeah
yeah apparently six is not the way to go
and b54 was stronger and now white is
very much ahead but yeah
not sure i can explain why apart from
the very simple you know rook better
than bishop we have more rooks
therefore we must win that makes sense
this position this position i like in
practical play i take black yeah but the
one we have now even in practical play
i'm not sure winning it is but
it feels believable believable you would
take white no like the rocks absolutely
yeah yeah
you would and he does play queen d1 and
chad is very much wondering why this is
the only move that gives a very very
large advantage and everything else was
immediately bringing it back into
probably
two you
your point is here you want to go some
b3 c3 and some move yeah like i have no
idea
i have no idea i can i can believe not
having to trade like i think
the idea that we preserve the option of
maybe keeping both rooks on the a file
in some positions and just generally
annoying black for a while yet
by keeping the rooks on and having them
calculate carson has played queen d1
which was praised by
chet and cece martial play is pawn to b4
and now the question is what white
should do next i was assuming but i
haven't looked at the computer yet that
one reason for queen to d1 could be to
go b3 here and not being hit by c3 with
tempo
but i'm not sure if there are any direct
intervals
some rook to a6 we should have one
coming
potentially tonight could come here
he did he was praised i believe yeah
also for this b3
c3 and now he's done something very
clever yeah
i think very clever it is he went
through k6
got the queen away from the v6 square
and is now planning to just put the
knight on c2 and that completely frees
up the bishop for
useful things
once the bishop joins black's defensive
lines actually collapse no like that
yeah i think i think once
once white actually you know the first
threat probably will be the
the last threat here anyway keeping both
rooks on on the a file alive is just so
annoying for black because you just you
just can't really
create any proper pressure i think some
sort of bishop f5 needs to be organized
very quickly like i think you need to
play rook g8 here
to at least be able to play knight
knight septupish per five
but maybe he just loses to knight e3
serving him well mm-hmm
and yeah
went f7 f6 i was wondering about that
not because i like the move but because
it feels like
staying passive will not work and this
is the one
way black has of not staying passive but
it probably just ends up losing you the
game faster
because your position just starts
collapsing faster after knight c2 we
don't even need to play four i think we
just go knight c2 yeah magnus in the
meantime found knight to d3 after xe5
knight takes in five and it's just it's
just over no yeah it looks over 95
rookie 6 is
just completely over i was wondering if
maybe you can go 94 here but it just
doesn't do anything like 24 bishop c5
but the issue is like everything wins
now i guess queen d3 is maybe the
cleanest just queen d3 queen e5 rook e6
just
the calmest and the cleanest reaction
and yeah that's just one check yeah it's
just a technical win c2 he's gone queen
e1 i have a feeling
almost any square is winning here but
in 93 rp7
c1
we
take on c1 i guess you know and then on
d5 in the end there and yeah there's
really no particular reason to continue
with black here two down and the knight
is
also not really participating all that
much in the proceedings here
deep on queens pretty much
yeah very clean game by magnus
sam did resign after roxy6 not not
unexpectedly
and shark did resign after magnus so we
suddenly have a an influx of
finished games and decisive finnish
games as well